[Musique]
lorsque nous arrivons en seine et marne
cet après-midi le ciel est noir et l'eau
commence à gagner certaines routes
nous atteignons la commune de souppes
sur loing ici les feux tricolores
semblent en service l'eau monte
l'angoissent aussi chez les habitants ça
le ce terrain ça monte en fait certains
de monter ouais vous partez ouais je
vais partir sa mort a présenté ce matin
c'était pas comme ça je n'en savante
c'est vraiment angoissant sur les
hauteurs de la ville
c'est un compte à rebours ne faut pas
les laisser on va le bouger nos arrivant
j'ai pas le plein de sujets comme ça
pour toutes les voitures doivent être
évacués à la hâte
bonjour monsieur bien sûr pas savouré la
queue toute la rue
toute la rue combien de voitures alors
c'est pour le on est à combien de
voitures avis owen la voie ferrée
ressemble déjà à un canal et des
centaines de personnes ont quitté leurs
habitations
nous accompagnons les pompiers dans une
zone reculée du village emmanuel mise à
l'eau dépasse les 1 mètre 50 par
endroits on distingue à peine ce portail
un peu plus loin une voiture engloutie
pour les pompiers il faut s'assurer
qu'aucun habitant ne soit encore en
danger
[Musique]
dans cette rue seules deux familles
refusent de partir
ça va ça va oui encore meilleur il ya
quatre personnes d'un matériel en
mandatant nathan de consommer les
chevaux moi si l'eau monte encore quand
les chevaux soit là on restera là tant
que l'on ne montera pas plus haut que ça
ça rentrera pas ici au pire les chevaux
les rentrera dans le salon et n'hésitez
surtout pas à nous rappeler 6 à 4 soit
les pompiers n'arriveront pas à les
convaincre
ce soir 780 personnes ont déjà été
évacuées de la commune devenue ville
fantôme et on commence par le choeur de
la crue la seine et marne on
l'apercevait du ciel le film de la
journée à mort et aux alentours clément
le goff tri sur le bras lorsque nous
arrivons à moret-sur-loing cet après
midi c'est une ville fantôme
personne dans les rues seul occupe la
route franchi les portails et encerclent
les maisons pas un bruit
le musée le stade ont été désertés les
habitations aussi sauf une dans la rue
principale un irréductible est resté
l'eau est à sa porte
vous êtes le dernier de la rua pas avoir
été vaincu jeune homme j'ai refusé
d'être évacuées
parce que j'avais j'avais pas eu le
temps de vider mais bibliothèques et des
tas d'objets les montées aux premiers
qui étaient des objets de valeur qui
aurait craint l'eau et je voulais pas
que ils risquent d'être transformé en
bouillie
parce qu'il a mis pour vous protéger
leur j'ai mis des idées des sacs de
sable des planches et puis j'ai bourré
tout avec du duduk veille du film
plastique pour eux étant chez g derrière
sa maison son jardin lui est déjà
inondés comme les autres et le niveau de
l'eau ne semble pas baisser
[Applaudissements]
la ville est traversée par la rivière et
regarder dans certains quartiers c'est
devenu un torrent pour nous impossible
d'aller plus loin dans la rue principale
quelques heures plus tôt ce matin dans
le village voisin de saint mamet c'est
un compte à rebours on se relaie pour
protéger les commerces avec des planches
et des parfums je suis bagdad depuis
hier depuis 7h30 du matin et je suis pas
rentrer à la maison là j'ai pas encore
dans l'ue voilà certains sauve
l'électroménager d'autres se mettent à
l'abri
le cas est submergé il faut quitter les
maisons
vous aviez déjà été évacués comme ça non
jamais on me dira quatre hommages 85 ans
pensée pour boire devant la mairie les
secours s'organisent une personne âgée
doit être évacué en urgence
c'est ce que j'aurais de toute urgence
la sarre compas morphine ne fonctionne
plus l'appui d'électricité depuis qu'il
ya soir à 22h donc on arriva enfin
d'autonomie de deux des appareillages
est ce que le dragon peut décoller je ne
sais pas c'est finalement un hélicoptère
de la sécurité civile qui viendra la
délivrer de sa maison à l'abri bien loin
des inondations mais au même moment
certaines péniche menace de basculer sur
le bateau suspect à travers la montée
faut prendre votre écran il faut les
amarres et celle ci sera attaché à un
arbre
un peu plus loin une autre est posé sur
le quai ce soir dans ces deux communes
l'eau n'est pas redescendue et peinent à
s'écouler sous les ponts et c'est
maintenant paris qui est placé depuis
quelques heures en alerte orange vous le
disais comme lors des grandes crues le
louvre va fermer ses portes demain pour
mettre ses trésors à l'abri on va
l'évoqué dans un instant d'abord regardé
le reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux ils
ont pu naviguer sur la seine la seine
qui monte d'heure en heure
you and roll à bruno girodon
c'est un fleuve méconnaissable qu'il
sillonne sans relâche avec la plus
grande prudence car la scène aujourd'hui
est un terrain miné
à chaque seconde elle charrie sur notre
route
ces dizaines d' obstacles que nous
devons contourner super attention
faut vraiment être vigilant sur
surtout les débris surtout les troncs
d'arbres
vu notre première intervention est une
urgence un bateau dont les amarres
menace de rompre un capitaine qu'il faut
aider et une approche à haut risque
il ya un contre courant qui nous qui
nous fait aller de droite à gauche
donc c'est très compliqué de maîtriser
de bateaux là vous en faites pas
remettre les amarres avec les moyens du
bord
sous le regard des curieux ont fait la
guerre ou pas sur la rive des policiers
vont aider à nouer les cordes
directement aux piles du pont
ça fait neuf ans que je suis ici j'ai vu
deux crus
c'était pas mal mais pas de cette
ampleur là lacer ses chaussures m
et quelle opération réussie sur la scène
circulation interdite aura des ponts les
policiers et les pompiers sont les seuls
à pouvoir naviguer
merci
ici la brigade doit surveiller ces
sommes une équipe de la sncf qui
condamne les voies d'aération du rer est
un peu plus haut cet homme qu il faut
dissuader de traverser les quinze inondé
embarque pas vraiment le temps de
s'attarder sur ce drôle de paysage sur
berge
car la scène continue de monter jusqu'à
dimanche jour et nuit tous les hommes de
la brigade fluviale resteront mobilisés
laurent des bonnets vous êtes en direct
à paris et en situation comme on dit
vraiment en situation avant des temps ce
soir est ce que l'eau continue à monter
oui on voit ici de rang en heure le
niveau continuer à monter sur ses quais
où d'habitude les parisiens peuvent
circuler jusqu'à ce poteau blanc ce
drapeau la scène a donc gagné au moins
trente mètres de largeur sur chaque rive
et vous le voyez on s'enfonce
extrêmement rapidement il faut être
prudent puisqu'il y a beaucoup de
courant beaucoup d'objets aussi charriés
par le fleuve des bouts de bois des
débris des panneaux de signalisation
emporté d'autres qui sont quasiment
totalement submergé comme ici cette
entrée d'un parking un parking qui est
totalement invisible ce soir les
péniches autour de moi ont toutes été
évacuées vous le voyez derrière moi les
ponts sur la seine paraissent désormais
très bas toute navigation et ce soir
impossible sur la scène merci laurent on
vous l'avait vu sur notre carte un grand
quart nord-est de la france est inondé
le fameux zouaves parisien et le château
de chambord ont les pieds dans l'eau et
la seine-et-marne le loiret reste donc
en alerte rouge inondations
l'équivalent d'un mois et demi de
précipitations y est tombé en trois
jours benoît mousser un paysage de
désolation
le loiret survolé aujourd'hui en
hélicoptère sur des kilomètres de l'eau
à perte de vue
en trois jours il est tombé sur ce
département l'équivalent d'un mois et
demi de précipitations
résultat des milliers d'habitations
inondées et des routes coupées feuilles
aux loges est l'une des premières
communes à avoir été touchés par ces
intempéries
après le déluge la solidarité s'organise
car beaucoup de sinistrés sont désormais
privés d'eau potable
on va rejoindre une barque pour
alimenter le lotissement
et pas mal sous l'eau et puis là le
tract à faire le tour de la ville pour
tous a donc là ça a été vraiment
beaucoup de solidarité heureusement on
soutient une seule est qu après le loire
et la seine et marne et le second
département avoir été placés en
vigilance rouge
ici aussi l'eau est montée très vite
comme dans le village de moret-sur-loing
donc pour l'instant on n'a pas encore
atteint 1910 qui est la prévision que
l'état nous allons le secteur le plus
critique reste concentrée autour de la
rivière du loup un qui continuent de
déborder les riverains les plus menacées
doivent partir et quitter leur maison a
late night mais en priorité tous nos
papiers les papiers de la maison la tour
de l'ordinateur il ya toutes les photos
depuis la naissance de nos enfants donc
ça ça a été des priorités voici l'a10
près d'orléans devenue en quelques
heures un fleuve une autoroute
aujourd'hui fermée est méconnaissable
avec ces véhicules abandonnés hier 500
automobilistes se sont retrouvés pris au
piège
ils ont été secourus par l'armée
a paris il est un baromètre le zouave du
pont de l'alma désormais les pieds dans
l'eau la scène a atteint aujourd'hui
quatre mètres 30 voies sur berge fermer
un cadre insolite pour les parisiens
comme pour les touristes
je viens souvent à paris je n'ai jamais
vu lui aussi aux nous sommes de londres
et la tamise ne monte jamais aussi les
visiteurs l'après cite également
chambord l'un des plus beaux châteaux de
france avait aussi des pieds dans l'eau
aujourd'hui une vision presque féerique
comme l'aurait rêvé françois 1er à paris
on ne parle donc plus que de lui
le zouave qui a de l'eau jusqu'à la
taille le pic de crue est atteint et
quand on compare avec le niveau normal
et bien on comprend l'ampleur du
phénomène
à 11 heures le dernier relevé indiqué si
m et l'eau devrait encore monter les
quais sont inondées et ceux qui habitent
tout près sont très inquiet caroline
sims jean-marie le quartier paris et ses
monuments les pieds dans l'eau une
barque pour se déplacer l'unique
solution trouvée par ses riverains du
16e arrondissement ce quartier bordant
les quais de seine pas loin de la tour
eiffel est inondée dans cette rue l'eau
est montée très vite comme le montre
cette photo prise hier à la grande
surprise des habitants
j'habite depuis trente deux ans le
quartier j'ai jamais vu ça de toute
façon un et quand ce propriétaire ouvre
ses volets ce matin c'est la surprise
hier est à peu près 20 cm d'envoyer là
on est vraiment à ras et on a des
plaques pour m'informer bons et parce
qu'elle a cru elle n'est pas finie l'ol
va encore monter ils disent jusqu'à midi
à peu près donc si c'est jusqu'à midi je
pense qu'on s'en sortira sinon si ça
continue ce soir où elle a coûté tout
est sous l'eau là dans les caves l'eau
pénètre par tous hélas et les
infiltrations
jusque là on est un niveau en dessous de
la scène
au sous-sol trois chambres de bonnes les
locataires ont fui impossible de lutter
contre l'eau avec nous on a peur quand
même
on les gens qui s'en remet à la scène
charrie des troncs d'arbres des gravats
plus un seul bateau mouche ne circule
depuis quelques jours les péniches
d'habitation sont désertés pour ceux qui
restent le canot est obligatoire
les touristes et les curieux ce
mastodonte dessus du pont de l'alma le
zouave à de l'eau presque jusqu'à la
ceinture c'est exceptionnel quand même
pour même si je suis pas très jeune
c'est quand même exceptionnel
ce qui est intéressant c'est la vitesse
de là où c'est ça qui fait peur parce
que plus que la hauteur avec les quais
de seine inondées
c'est le coeur de paris qui est atteint
le niveau du fleuve devrait encore
monter les musées d'orsay et du louvre
qui se trouve au bord de la seine sont
fermées au public des oeuvres sont
déplacés et mise en sécurité au louvre
pas moins de deux cent mille pièces
seraient en zone inondable nicolas
lemarignier daniel wolfromm et annie
three bars fermés pour cause
d'inondation depuis ce matin
le louvre est vide plus un visiteur la
priorité c'est d'évacuer les oeuvres
d'art qui sont situées en zone inondable
dans les salles des étages les caisses
s'entassent ce sont les réserves qui
sont concernés par le plan de prévention
deux cent mille objets mais aussi le
département des arts de l'islam
fermée hier après midi quatorze mille
objets 3500 oeuvre ce matin la ministre
de la culture est venu sur place pour
constater l'avancée de l'opération salué
la mobilisation intense qui a été celle
des personnels
des personnels les plus directement
dédié à cela mais aussi des volontaires
des volontaires qui se sont mobilisés
aussi pour que tout soit fait en temps
et heure
depuis 2002 un plan de prévention
existent pompiers de paris personnel du
musée et volontaire tous sont formés à
ces situations de crise dans cet endroit
si particulier pour les autres
établissements situés le long de la
seine
l'urgence est moins pressante le musée
d'orsay a transféré une bonne partie de
ses réserves dans des bâtiments de
stockage extérieur au musée du quai
branly les risques d'inondation ont été
pris en compte dès la construction il ya
dix ans le bâtiment peut supporter une
crue jusqu'à sept mètres
sur les routes mais également trafic en
partie interrompu sur la ligne c du rer
plusieurs stations de métro ont
également été fermés bref difficile de
se déplacer encore aujourd'hui à paris
qu'à me buttin fred avec bazire sur le
rer c des voix noyée
l'eau s'est infiltrée partout sur les
rails impossible pour les trains de
circuler tout le trafic est arrêtée
entre la gare d'austerlitz et de
versailles les stations de métro elles
aussi sont inondés à saint michel ou
encore à cluny la sorbonne
toutes les entrées sont fermés résultat
sur les autres lignes
depuis ce matin ça se bouscule sur ce
cas il faut attendre longtemps avant de
jouer des coudes pour entrer dans le
wagon compliqué pour les voyageurs
en c'est quand on part on sait pas quand
on arrive donc je pense que je vais
mettre une bonne heure et quart
peut-être plus c'était métro taxis bus
en bref la totale
c'était un koh lanta urbain moi je vais
descendre la bibliothèque françois
mitterrand j'avais points de la ligne 14
pour rejoindre la gare de lyon et de la
gare de lyon je vais à la défense et la
défense je prends le train qui veulent à
verrières pour descendre à montigné
voilà des inondations qui s'ajoute à la
grève qui frappe la sncf son patron
guillaume pepy appel ce soir les
syndicats à reprendre le travail
par solidarité aux cours et ne serait ce
qu'un instant mettre son drapeau dans sa
poche et cette suspension je pense que
tout le monde devrait y réfléchir
sérieusement parce que c'est ça qu'il
faut faire au moins en ile-de-france et
en région centre
malgré cet appel les syndicats ont voté
la grève enfin sur les routes toutes les
voies sur berges sont impraticables
elles devraient rester fermés au moins
jusqu'à lundi paris la capitale et la
scène est en alerte vigilance orange
le fameux zouave du pont de l'alma à de
l'eau maintenant jusqu'aux genoux sait
plus qui hier alors pour l'instant on
est encore loin de la crue de 1910 mais
la prudence est de mise dans la capitale
même le louvre et le musée d'orsay ont
décidé de fermer leurs portes pour
mettre leurs oeuvres qui sont dans les
airs réserve les mettre à l'abri
laurent blanc et pascal comptons passer
la journée avec la brigade fluviale sur
la scène
regardez le reportage
les hommes de la brigade fluviale sont
appelés en urgence la scène vient de
dépasser les 5 mètres 20 dont les
péniches de nombreux habitants sont
prises au piège
en fait il ya un moment où sans qu'ils
ne peuvent plus se débrouiller par
eux-mêmes nous appelle donc les rangs
des voix ils sont ils sont sur leur
bateau
les amarres du bateau tiennent toujours
mais avec la crue c'est passager n'ont
plus accès à la terre ferme pas
d'urgence vitale
mais cette jeune femme doit
impérativement quitter le bateau je dois
vraiment rentrer à la maison ils l'ont
secouru je suis heureuse et je les
remercier depuis 48 heures les
conditions de travail des policiers de
la fluviale sont excécrables à chaque
pont la même tension
si tu passes
à droite la droite parce que tu passe
plus
le zodiac est tout juste passé mais pour
combien de temps encore autre difficulté
les débris en tous genres charriés par
la scène table souche d'arbre branche
le bateau doit slalomer pour éviter que
cela ne se coince dans les lices le riz
s'est cassé un moteur et si trop de si
on allait trop vite le risque de partir
à l'eau aussi si jamais ça taper trop
fort
les interventions s'enchaînent sur cette
péniche les habitants ont mis en
sécurité leurs meubles mais leurs
voitures garées en contrebas sont
immergés le courant menacent de les
faire dériver
on a au moins une journée entre le
moment où ça monte un peu là-bas et là
en deux heures c'était s'était monté
plus haut que jamais face à l'ampleur de
la crue tous les hommes en congés sont
revenus spontanément travail et les
cadres et les mécaniciens eux aussi sont
sortis de la brigade pour sécuriser le
fleuve
voilà une montée des eaux pour l'instant
jusqu'à cette hauteur là j'en ai
quelques-uns qui ont connu mais n'a plus
beaucoup donc ça un petit peu
exceptionnel pour nous
les équipes de la brigade fluviale
s'attendent à vivre des heures
difficiles
le pic de crue n'est attendu que demain
d'ici là la scène pourrait encore monter
d'un mètre
françois hollande l'a annoncé l'état de
catastrophe naturelle sera reconnue dès
mercredi pour enclencher le processus
d'indemnisation les sinistrés auront dix
jours pour effectuer une déclaration de
sinistre
les particuliers ont beaucoup souffert
mais les commerçants aussi ce reportage
à corbeil essonnes de johanna jacquot
albrecht est de 10 bassompierre à
corbeil essonnes la scène continue de
monter et les commerçants s'inquiètent
jusqu'ici le voile et là il ya un mètre
à un mètre cinquante même pas si ça veut
dire si ça s'arrête pas vite
ben ça va mieux restaurant et après le
restaurant les futures mais le
restaurant reste ouvert tant qu'il le
pourra le gérant veut continuer à
travailler
on est demandée on a tous un bol des
frigos des bouteilles la marchandise on
a tout perdu
aux alentours du fleuve
l'eau s'infiltre partout ce bureau tabac
a dû fermer il ne peut plus rien rendre
toute la marchandise est perdu il faut
la faire repartir chez le fournisseur
est recommandée ou du produit qui offre
dans d'autres entreprises
on essaye encore de lutter contre la
montée des eaux
on est en train d'essayer de sauver un
bon contrôle de freinage mais sa voix la
peau des fesses
et puis puis on a des atouts surélevé on
fait au mieux pour limiter les dégâts
une machine à plus de 40000 euros sans
compter le coût de la fermeture forcée
du garage et une perte d'activité et
l'assurance de temps et que les experts
parce qu'ils évaluent n'espérant ponte
archives seront pas inonder qu'on pourra
retrouver toutes les factures et puis
voilà quoi ici comme dans tout le
département
difficile d'évaluer le montant des
dommages dont que les eaux ne se seront
pas retirés
bienvenue à tous il ya une semaine tout
juste les rivières et les fleuves
sortait de leur cours une partie de la
france avait les pieds dans l'eau
aujourd'hui l'heure est donc à la décrue
mais un département reste au centre des
regards l'essonne là-bas l'eau monte
encore les habitants ne sont pas tirés
d'affaires mathieu boisseau eric de la
nuit depuis l'hélicoptère pas de doute
la scène est toujours hors de son lit
ici à morsang sur seine les jardins des
maisons restent inondées et la rue n'est
qu'à quelques mètres en quatre jours il
est tombé l'équivalent de deux mois de
pluie
quelques mètres plus loin on ne
distingue plus grand chose de ce court
de tennis
la scène reste à un niveau très élevé
mais la décrue s'amorce la nouvelle
menace
c'est désormais l'essonne d'habitude un
petit affluent aujourd'hui une rivière
surpuissante trois mètres de crue et un
débit 20 fois supérieur à la normale à
corbeil-essonnes l'eau s'infiltre déjà
près des maisons du travail j'ai eu la
surprise de voir ça on voit plus la
délimitation entre le bras de l'essonne
et la parcelle les barrages résiste
encore mais c'est une certitude
l'essonne va continuer de déborder 80000
habitants sont concernés ceux qui n'ont
pas encore évacué se prépare comme ils
le peuvent
on a essayé de protéger en notant des
bastaings de bois du pôle yann des sacs
de sable on s'est dit que ça limiterait
le ruissellement après s'il ya un maître
donnant garage
clairement ça servira pas ce soir le
département de l'essonne restent placés
en vigilance orange
le pic de crue est attendue dans les
prochaines heures
[Musique]